paying what they should be paying
they're paying close to 1% and they're
supposed to be paying 2% and the United
States over the years got to a point
where it's paid four point three percent
which is very unfair and the u.s. GDP
especially under me because the GDP has
gone up so much because it's four point
three of a much larger GDP so we're
paying for a big proportion of NATO
which basically is protecting Europe so
we're protecting Europe okay let's go
straight to Brussels where a DW is teri
Schultz standing by for us good morning
Terry a president Trump they're pressing
NATO allies once again he's been doing
that since he took office to spend more
as NATO marks its 70th birthday can you
give us a picture of NATO's financial
health on this birthday and and of its
unity Secretary General Stoltenberg
points out every chance he gets
particularly every chance he gets when
he's sitting next to Donald Trump to say
that allies have turned around the
spending decreases of a decade ago and
that since President Trump took office
which is the period that Stoltenberg
uses when he's with President Trump he
says a hundred billion euros more a
hundred billion dollars more has been
spent or projected to be spent by NATO
allies since 2016 in fact the spending
turn around
happened in 2014 but it is true that all
allies are now moving in the right
direction what President Trump mixes up
continuously is that country's own
defense spending is also automatically
NATO's budget what he's pressing allies
to do is actually have to spend more on
their own defense which would then of
course put more resources in NATO's
hands as well but in fact that is a good
news story and many European allies wish
mr. Trump would simply call a win a win
and praise them for spending increases
instead of continuing to look at the
glass half full on this
we will now proceed to the signing of
the North Atlantic Treaty the 70 year
old NATO has faced examinations under
harsh light this birthday
it does have some concerns for its
well-being discomfort when something
viral is going around occasional spikes
in blood pressure and perhaps some
self-doubt that when push comes to shove
its core is not as strong as it hoped to
former u.s. ambassadors to NATO
researched the biggest threat facing the
Alliance of 70 the transatlantic
consensus the absence of strong American
presidential leadership NATO
secretary-general Jens Stoltenberg
rejects that conclusion
it's just not possible to say that that
the United States is not committed to
NATO because the United States is
increasing their military contributions
to NATO he points to the latest example
a new plan for the u.s. to forward
position heavy war fighting equipment at
a Polish Air Base Trump's rough
treatment of the Alliance particularly
his incessant demand that governments
spend more on defense has unnerved some
Europeans but this shake-up some call it
a shakedown by the US President may have
some benefits for NATO I've never seen
so many editorials in American
newspapers praising the Alliance Jamie
Shay spent almost four decades at NATO
as a spokesman but also an expert in
what are called emerging security
challenges and while dealing with Russia
and it's hybrid warfare tactics still
topped the list of challenges for NATO
the now-retired che warns the alliance
must look further afield to be fit for
the future because obviously China is
the rising power it's already in Europe
or buying up infrastructure influencing
the future of artificial intelligence
technology it's going to be a massively
more important factor in determining
21st century security than Russia or
arguably any other country outside NATO
but countries insider shaping NATO's
future to the next enlargement will be
to North Macedonia which changed its
name to settle a dispute with Greece
that earned an almost immediate
invitation to join pending the approval
of the other 29 allies they didn't waste
their time they didn't drag their feet
and that's remarkable for an
organization of 29 members so I think
that it's not just our desire to join
it's how NATO has dealt with the
challenge of enlargement that shows that
this is a strong forward-looking and
dynamic organization skopje hopes the
alliance will prove this anniversary
year that 70 is the new 30 70 is the new
30 terrier piece they're focusing on on
north macedonia but it's not just that
country NATO's also indicated it's open
to taking in former Soviet states like
Georgia even Ukraine how big does the
Alliance want to get in fact there's not
a lot of appetite at the moment even to
expand to those countries which have
membership action plans which are
already on the road to NATO membership
North Macedonia was a special case it
had been under discussion for decades
and blocked by Greece's opposition on
the name of course that's that's another
story
so North Macedonia was had an easier
path in some of these other countries
but they do still speak with Georgia and
Ukraine about about joining and in fact
when those countries fulfilled their
obligations which a reformed rule of law
level of military readiness they will
very likely get into NATO but further
afield I don't think it's likely at this
moment there aren't that many other
countries asking to join and NATO has to
think very carefully about where it
wants article 5 to extend to eteri we
heard Jamie Shea in your piece saying
that the strategic threat posed to
Europe by China is being underestimated
by the security community what what our
NATO experts saying about Beijing and
its threat to Europe I thought that was
very interesting too from Jamie Shaye
and in fact as he said in my piece he
said it will be more important
strategically than Russia which is
something that you we really haven't
been paying enough attention to so what
ashay suggests is that NATO set up a
China Commission there they don't have
high-level meetings regularly with China
and he says that's a mistake that even
though you don't have an adversarial
relationship so you want to start this
relationship when things are not hostile
because he says China is doing things
like buying up ports in Europe which
would need to be at the military's hands
it's something if a conflict did break
out so NATO experts are not saying
enough about China according to Jamie
Shay okay and perhaps this will be
figuring more largely in the news moving
forward teri Schultz for us in Brussels
thank you very much